[Musique]
je conseil municipal
voilà
un
mail qui nous dit qu'il faut voter
contre marine le pen dans les eaux enfin
attendez le président de la commission
médicale d'établissement qui nous dit
comment on doit voter non mais attendez
c'est trop politisé tout ça c'est qu'il
faut se calmer pour ça que je vous dis
pas ni pour qui voter ni pour qui je
vais voter parce que ça vous regarde pas
je veux plus entendre de ma vie
je vais je refuse de participer
[Musique]
jeu
on prend l'antenne dans neuf minutes
apolline de malherbe y avoir une
révélation
elle se fait c'est non mais attendez
c'est très important tous demandent
pardon vous rendez pas compte chaque
détail compte et en fait moi quand je
fais du coloriage ça me détend je fais
du côlon hockey secrets de stars
apolline de madère
[Musique]